[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
ne va plus en cours depuis presque un
mois
[Musique]
je voulais te demander comment ça va il
s'est passé quelque chose tu te rends
compte que le lycée envisage de te
renvoyer
je peux vivre avec toi
tu dis que tu ne te sens pas très proche
des gens de ton âge
dans notre vie ceci a besoin de toi et
tu travailles à longueur de journée
est-ce qu'il a réussi à parler du
divorce
j'ai essayé de te soutenir de donner de
la force qu'est-ce qui se passe tu te
drogues tu crois vraiment que tu peux
vivre comme ça en faisant ce que tu as
envie de faire
je comprends pas ce qui m'arrive
j'ai l'impression d'avoir tout raté
il y avait tellement de joie dans notre
famille tu fais toujours tes beaux
sermon sur la vie et après tu nous
abandonnes je le droit de refaire ma vie
ah mon fils tu es venu me dire que Dieu
modèle tu veux que je t'appeler au 10
c'est mon petit garçon je peux pas le
laisser tomber
[Musique]